all right Louis let's get to my most
popular Instagram posts of the last week
of course i'm on instagram at david
pakman this is the only platform where
you can see things like bizarre pictures
of me from weddings which i will get to
in a second first of all some of my my
cooking pictures have done stunningly
well and i put up a picture last night
of an extraordinary chicken dish that I
made which I will show you here what is
your assessment here Louis of this dish
which I've never actually done this
before I first sauteed the chicken in a
very old heavy cast-iron skillet then
put the entire thing in the oven and it
came out extraordinarily well yes well
that's a that's a great technique and it
looks delicious I have to be honest this
is I can get behind this one this is me
winning again because I used to never
win with my Instagram pictures and I was
finally winning again listen David has
done tremendously well in the kitchen
I've done tremendously well with the
cast-iron skillets okay so people seem
to like that and then also I was at a
wedding in Cape Cod over the weekend get
your kids out of the room quick a
picture of me was taken with a few
people and it was one of these things
where the Sun was right in my eyes and I
thought listen it took it's one picture
I can stand with my my eyes open and
smile and I won't be hugely negatively
affected by the Sun and unfortunately I
couldn't deal with it and what ended up
is me with an expression on my face that
is a combination of me crying and I and
having what really is a very bizarre and
creepy look on my face right
interestingly the the lens of the camera
exploded a millisecond after this photo
was taken
yes so this people very shocked and
appalled that this this was my physical
appearance during a wedding where
children were actually attending or yeah
I just couldn't take it I mean it was
just so bright that this is what it led
to it is one of the most bizarre
pictures of my face that has been
released on the internet probably in the
last 10 years I would say yes I'd say
that this one is far more disturbing
than the picture of you pregnant as a
toddler yeah but it was a picture where
I appeared to be pregnant at age 2 which
with was posted okay so that's that
remember you can follow me on Instagram
I am David Pakman on Instagram and that
is that
don't miss this picture